whatup Space Cowboys goes in here for
anime uproar and today I'm going to be
talking about the twelve demon moons and
everything we know about their powers
villains are always a blast to talk
about so I've been looking forward to
this video especially because Demon
Slayer has some of the best written
villains in anime if you enjoy seeing
demon saticons on this channel make sure
to smash that like button for more if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you actually
get notified when a new video drops and
if that ain't enough content for you you
can also follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar there will be
manga spoilers in this video and now
without further ado let's jump into it
first let me explain how the twelve
moons are organized they are divided
into six lower moons who have their
number in one eye and six upper moons
who have their numbers in both eyes
directly below upper moon six you have
lower moon one rather than moon seven
the weakest is lower moon six and the
strongest is upper moon one we'll start
with the weakest lower moon six lower
moon six used to be cure guy the drum
demon however he slowly lost the ability
to eat humans Mouzon was disappointed
that he had already reached his limit
and took away his lower moon six title
so he failed as a demon moon he tried
his hand at writing but he was told it's
boring he was told that everything he
wrote was trash and that he should stop
writing he did not respond well to the
criticism and killed the harsh critic
using his demon powers so he failed at
writing to his whole life he was told by
people that he wasn't good enough only
tons you know as he kills him praises
him he says that his blood demon art is
very impressive and that actually makes
kyo guy happy he asks tons you know if
it is really strong and ton zero says
it's very strong yoga has touched a ton
shit'll saw value in him when everyone
else had always told him that he was
worthless he's touched that ton 0
recognized that his manuscripts don't
deserve to be stepped on yoga was so
overwhelmed that he began to cry as he
disappeared he was a demon and he killed
people so he had to be stopped however
his dying scene shows that Kyo guy's
life might have been very different if
only he was surrounded by people who
recognized his value
earlier on rather than people who
consciously put him down and made him
feel worthless it definitely took more
than demon blood to turn him into a
monster now let's talk about his
impressive powers he can manipulate his
drum house by using the drums all over
his body not only can he make the house
rotate left-right forwards and backwards
he can use the drum on his chest to
create a claw attack and the drum on his
back to teleport himself into another
room he can increase the speed of his
drumming to increase the speed of
rotation and a number of slashes that
appear when he uses his claw attack I
have to admit along with tons you know I
was impressed by the drum powers when I
saw them in action
the newer lower moon six was named
common way after lower Moon five rui was
killed moves on called the lower demons
together including common when he is
furious that the lower demons are so
weak common new is the first lower moon
moves on kills not because he talked
back but because he thought back moves
on can read all of people's thoughts if
he gave them blood and if they are
invisible range so he kills coming the
way before he turns his attention to the
other lower demons unfortunately come on
Noah dies before we get to see his
unique powers lower moon five was the
ruie the cool looking spider-man demon
this has got to be one of my favorite
character designs in a series so far his
backstory is tragic like that of most
demons Rui was born with a weak body he
never ran and it was even difficult for
him to walk Mouzon helped him get a
strong body by turning him into a demon
the only problem was now he had to eat
people and he had to avoid the Sun at
all costs his parents wanted him to have
a strong body but they were devastated
by the fact that he began killing humans
once upon a time Rui was touched by a
story he heard where parents died in
order to save their child who was
drowning in a river he was moved by the
parental love and the bond that caused
them to sacrifice their own lives for
another he always wanted that bond but
his family tried to kill him instead
so Rui killed them and began searching
for real bonds he created a fake spider
family and tried to force family bonds
using fear obviously that didn't work
but he eventually realized that the bond
he had with his parents was genuine they
weren't bad people they were going to
kill Rui and then
kill themselves the fact that really
killed innocent people and would
continue to kill innocent people could
not be overlooked but his parents were
ready to atone with him by sacrificing
their own lives even as she was dying
ruies mother apologized because she
couldn't give him a healthy body there
was a genuine bond there but the ruie
thought he had severed it by killing
them
however as he's dying he sees his
parents again they welcome him back with
open arms and forgive all of his actions
they're going to follow Italy wherever
he goes even if it's hell even though
they committed no sins
this is one of the most touching moments
in the series and it illustrates the
fact that the ruie had the strongest of
family bonds to begin with do we
apologize he takes full responsibility
for everything and cries in the arms of
his loving parents as the flames of hell
approached the reunited family I give 10
billion points to the mangaka for being
able to make me sympathize with a
character who seemed so cold and brutal
in the beginning and even hurt our
precious nez Zuko on to the
spider-powers
Italy easily our class's cure guy and
that's reflected in the fact that tan
judo and that Zuko unlock new opie
abilities and it's still not enough to
defeat him this demon fights with spider
webs that are insanely strong and sharp
when he goes full power the threads turn
red and are even more powerful despite
how epic the dancer the fire-god was and
all man was an epic Louie was
intelligent enough to use his strings to
rip off his own head so that he can
simply attach it later however he was no
match for gil who not only rendered the
opie red strings meaningless with his
law ability but went on to cut off the
demons head in the blink of an eye
before he could even remove it himself
to put the cherry on top of the cake GU
had a completely stoic emotionless face
when he cut this Opie demons head off
when all the screaming and emotions in
the world couldn't help ton zero defeat
that same demon I must say the way Ruiz
death is written all the way from his
fight with ton zero to his family
reunion in the afterlife is pure genius
lower wound for was called moukaku
he was a - horned demon and he was the
most cowardly out of all the demon moons
moves on read his mind and figured out
that mukha goal always intended to flee
if he ever encountered a demon hunter
pillar obviously moves on
going to punish such cowardice he
quickly kills the sweating and crying
MOOC ago and as was common new way we
never get to figure out what mu cago
specific powers were lower moon 3 was
called lacunae BA
he had X shaped scars on his forehead
and cheeks he tries to run away from
Mouzon before he can kill him but moves
on quickly behead sin we never get to
see Walker Ava's powers lower moon 2 was
called the Rope guru he begged Mulan not
to kill him he said he would definitely
be useful to Musa he tells Mouzon to
give him more of his blood and he'll
become stronger but the fact that a
lower moon would dare give him
instructions only infuriates Musa and
those the end of the line for Wakaba
his powers were also not revealed
unfortunately but don't worry we get to
see all of the stronger demons beyond
this point use their OB powers lower
moon one was the sadistic and mu and mu
perhaps unintentionally used reverse
psychology on Musa and it worked
wonderfully while the others were
begging for their lives and MU was
excited by the prospect of moves on
personally killing him rather than
fearing that the sadistic demon was
grateful that moves on saves him for
last and allowed him to listen to the
screams of the other lower demons Mouzon
was won over by an Moo's unorthodox
behavior and instead of killing him
Mulan gave him an abundance of his blood
to make him stronger his special powers
allow him to enter someone's dreams and
he can destroy their minds by destroying
their spiritual core within the dream
however going into someone's dreams can
be dangerous so he sends others in his
stead to locate and destroy his enemies
spiritual core additionally his blood
which he mixes into the train tickets
puts people to sleep if they touch it if
all that wasn't enough he can also
assimilate his body with large inanimate
objects like a train in this way he can
potentially eat and assimilate all of
the hundreds of train passengers he can
detach body parts like hands or his head
and they can continue to move and even
talk as well his talking hands can even
hypnotize people into falling asleep
this guy is just full of handy tricks
however tons Rose dance at the fire-god
cuts through his trained spine and
effectively puts an end to end Mo's
dreams the title of upper moon
excuse to belong to daki the hottest
demon ever and her not so attractive
brother kutaro so let's start with their
tragic backstory dakis real name was ma
which was the name of the disease that
killed her mother
daki and guitarra were born poor and
they started out at the bottom of the
food chain in the red-light district
they were a burden because it cost money
to feed the siblings and keep them alive
buta role was born first and his mother
tried to kill him many times because he
was such a nuisance to her he had a weak
body but he desperately tried to stay
alive and he did everyone laughed at him
because of his ugly voice and appearance
and if the words couldn't hurt him the
rocks they threw at him definitely could
he was ugly dirty covered in dirt and
dandruff and smelled bad because of all
the fleas in a place that values beauty
above all else he was viewed like a
monster and he had to resort to eating
rats and bugs when he was hungry
now sorry to Drake but that's the actual
bottom and gue taro is the one who
started from it however when uma was
born something changed
she was guilt arose pride and joy in
contrast to him she was exceptionally
pretty he realized that he was great at
fighting and train so that he could use
a sickle effectively he became a
collector people feared him and were
disgusted because of his ugly appearance
but he began to take pride in his
ugliness now it felt great his beautiful
sister blew away his sense of
inferiority he wanted both of them to
work together to create better lives for
themselves but this dream was
complicated when ma turned 13 and poked
out a samurais eye with her hairpin she
was tied up and burned alive while GU
taro was away when he came back his
sister was burned to a crisp
you thought Oh screamed at the injustice
as tears flooded down his eyes then
while he was mourning he was attacked
from behind by the samurai he killed the
samurai who as guitarra points out lived
in a house that sheltered him from the
wind and rain
the samurai was spoiled by comparison he
had a nice kimono nice skin full meals
and a beautiful futon probably and this
spoiled guy took the one thing GU Toto
had going for him his sister and then
tried to take his life to the
indignation that you Thoreau must
felt it's clear he struggled his whole
life and worked ceaselessly so he could
create a better future for his sister
and then in an instant someone who was
born with everything burned her alive
like it was nothing
not only did he have no remorse the
samurai tried to kill Goethe wrote to
after he killed the samurai he took his
sister and searched for help but as
usual no one would come and help them he
finally collapsed on the snowy ground
then upper moon too came and he gave
them both his blood including the all
but dead umeå butanone ever regretted
this decision to become a demon because
it meant saving his little sister he
also couldn't forgive others for having
better lives and so he decided that
he'll snatch away those lives and
collect them in the end after being
defeated Yuto feels bad not for himself
but for umeå he believes that she would
have had a better life if he hadn't
raised her he feels like he corrupted
her in purgatory he tells his sister not
to follow him because he wants her to be
free from his corruptive influence
however you may just apologizes for
everything and runs to hug him she says
that she won't let go and that they'll
be together forever
Yuto is touched then together they move
forward as flames surround them this is
another one of the most touching moments
in the manga you can feel for these two
despite all the horrible things they've
done it's bittersweet
it's sad that they were born in such a
cruel and unfair world but it's kind of
beautiful that in the middle of all that
pain and suffering they had each other
well what's really sad is that I won't
get to see da ki the hottest woman in
anime for the rest of the series now
let's talk about their powers da ki
fights with what appears to be fabrics
of clothing that she can manipulate that
will these fabrics are shaped like
scarves are strong enough to block
Nichiren blades and are sharp enough to
cut down her opponents she can use these
scarves like an octopus uses tentacles
she's like a much stronger and sexier
Doc Ock she can turn her own body at the
similar material for instance if someone
tries to cut off her neck she can turn
it into this fabric and it will Bend
with the sword making it harder to cut
she can also store living people inside
her scarves which she does to keep her
food fresh she can even attach part of
herself and that scarf can act on its
own and watch over things like her
stores of living human victims
there's Guterres powers guitarra already
had skills using a sickle and his demon
powers allow him to capitalize on those
skills he can use his flesh and blood to
create sickles that are coated with
fatal poison he can send countless blood
leads flying at his opponents he can
also take control of his sister's body
and create perfectly coordinated
tag-team attacks another added benefit
of disability is that both his head and
his sister's head have to be cut off at
the same time or they will simply
regenerate in the end akheon you total
were defeated
but it took a pillar a number of
talented demon hunters a protagonist
opie demon sister some wives and
probably some good old-fashioned luck to
just barely win this was one of my
favorite arcs if not my favorite in the
series in a large part of the reason is
because da ki and Yuto
made for such amazing and powerful
antagonists I can't wait to see this
part animated the title of upper moon
sex went on to get inherited by Kai Goku
who was pre osya demon hunter and zani
to sampai Kai Goku and zenit sue studied
under the same Thunder style sensei just
a quick note sometimes thunder style is
translated as lightning style but I'll
be using thunder style in this video
anyways because his one student became a
demon is any - sensei committed seppuku
or ritual suicide and no one was even
there to cut off his head so he suffered
a long and agonizing death kai gaku is
glad that his former sensei died
painfully because he worked so hard and
he was never given the Thunder style
successor title the sense they wanted
Kai Goku who could use every Thunder
style breath except the first one to
share the successorship with is any two
who could only use the first one the
demon blood made Kai Goku Thunder style
even stronger but he still lost lose any
to who created his own seventh breath
called flaming Thunder God you should or
later points out that kagaku still had
no idea how to use his newfound diva
techniques and abilities so sunny too
was lucky because he would have lost if
Kai gaku had more time to get used to
his demon powers his reinforced Thunder
style allows kagaku to launch multiple
attacks at a single moment attack from
all directions strike from a distance
crack bodies and burned flesh upper moon
5 was
yoku the genie with two mouths where his
eyes should be and an eye where his
mouth should be he creates gruesome
works of art out of the bodies of his
human victims Muccino the mist pillar is
the one who faces off against him mu
Ichiro starts to grow marks on his face
and with his increased power manages to
defeat Yoko
by cutting off his head with a quick
slash one of those quick slashes that
takes a second to show the damage now
let's talk about his powers he has
multiple pots and he can teleport
between them until the pots are
destroyed he has another form you can
enter when he needs more power in this
form he is covered in scales that are
harder than diamonds and everything his
fists touch turns into sweet little fish
to use his own words he calls himself in
existence that knows no bounds in this
form which is why it's even funnier when
a 14 year old kid kills him lastly can
summon octopus tentacles from his jar he
can trap enemies in suspended water and
he can release fish like demons that
feed on enemy flesh and even if the
enemy cuts them they'll release a
poisonous liquid that can be absorbed
through the skin
upper moon for was Han tangu Opie in his
own way but definitely a coward of a
demon we get glimpses of his past as a
human he was a mentally unstable person
who stole and killed people and blamed
it on his uncontrollable hands thus he
always felt like a victim and viewed
people who were trying to bring him to
justice as bullies but ton j'adore
manages to finish him off this demon has
impressive stealth skills he can sneak
into the blacksmith village and he can
even sneak up to both MU Ichiro and tan
zero two skilled and experienced demon
Slayers his small body also makes him
hard to spot and hit he can divide his
emotions and they'll manifest in
different forms that will fight for him
he makes an anger clone that fights with
lightning a joy to own that fights with
wind a sorrow clone that fights with a
spear a pleasure clone that fights with
sound a fear clone with high defensive
abilities that contains hunting ghouls
core and a large resentment clone a last
line of defense that hides the original
demon in its heart the anger clone can
also absorb other emotion clones to
create the more powerful hatred clone
that appears to be able to use all the
other power
in one for instance it could use the
pleasure clone sonic scream it can also
summon powerful wooden dragon heads and
as we know multiple dragon heads are
always pretty cool the title of upper
moon for got passed down to knock he
made the emotionless Cyclops musician as
Mitsuda points out Malcolm a can move
her building as if it were her own hands
and feet
we're told her powers aren't very deadly
but they make her very difficult to
defeat she is like an advanced version
of former lower Moon 6 demon cure guy
while Kyo guy controls his house na kimi
controls what seems to be an infinite
interdimensional fortress she can bring
anyone she desires into the fortress and
she is able to create teleporting doors
wherever she wants this way she can
teleport her ponent somewhere else if
they tried to attack her she can also
create several detached eyeballs from
her body and use them to spy on people
from long range
this ability allowed her to locate many
demon hunters across Japan it even
allowed her to locate the well-hidden
mansion of kebaya Ubu Isshiki which was
for a long time probably one of the
best-kept secrets in the world upper
moon 3 was a casa who actually had one
of the best backstories and character
arcs in the series so far I definitely
didn't think I'd feel this way after he
killed the flame pillar man Goku but the
manga pulled off some top-tier writing
witchcraft and maybe empathize with
Icaza even though I didn't want to and
keep in mind moving forward he was 18
when he became a demon so he was still
practically a kid but let's take a look
at his life up to becoming a demon he
was born with fangs so he was called a
demon child all his life
when he was growing up Acosta had a sick
father who needed expensive medicine so
from a young age Icaza was forced to
steal so he can afford the medicine the
tattoos on his demon body seemed to be
inspired by actual tattoos he was given
as a kid for pickpocketing he was
visibly marked as a criminal for all to
see at a very young age he felt like he
had to become stronger so he could run
away with more wallets beat up people
who came for revenge and escaped the
magistrate after receiving three
pickpocketing tattoos he was told that
his wrist would be cut off next time but
an 11 year old Icaza after receiving 100
blows told them to go ahead and cut his
wrists off since he'd still have his
feet to use for pickpocketing then one
day he got some really heartbreaking
news
his father had hung himself because he
wanted Acosta to live an honest life and
he didn't want to live off money that
was stolen from others in a letter he
apologized for being a nuisance to his
son
however Acosta never viewed his father
as a nuisance his father never did
anything wrong in fact his father was a
kazoos reason for living he would have
gladly endured the harshest punishments
for his dad even if they lasted a
hundred years after his father killed
himself Acosta hugged his grave and
cursed the unjust world he got into
brawls with people and in one instance
he beat up seven adults with his bare
fists that's when kaizo the bare fists
of martial arts master entered his life
and whooped
akiza's but for his own good he took a
casa into his home despite the fact that
he was banished from Edo for being a
criminal not only that he trusted him to
take care of his sick daughter while he
was at work his wife used to do it where
she drowned herself from the fatigue of
nursing her she feared that her daughter
would only get worse and worse until she
died and she couldn't just wait for that
to happen anymore
I cuz I started caring for koyuki his
sensei's daughter and he fell in love
with her he had hit rock bottom when his
dad died but he finally found a new
reason to live and things eventually got
better than they've ever been
akasa was such a good guy that he hated
when people apologize for being sick he
knew that they would help themselves if
they could and more importantly he
wanted to help them he never saw helping
others as a bother rather he saw it as
the least he could do at one point
koyuki feels bad that causes missing out
because of her and asks him to go watch
the fireworks
however he prefers to stay by her side
and tells her that they'll go next year
or the year after that he wants to go
see them with her when she's feeling
better
Kuki was so touched that she cried akasa
found out that his sensei got the dojo
when he saved the previous owner however
other people were jealous and made sure
that he had no students Icaza was saved
by his sensei and his daughter training
in the dojo and nursing koyuki healed
his heart he was there for over three
years and koyuki was starting to
normally I cuz the sensei offered Icaza
his dojo and his daughter's hand in
marriage because he had the tattoos of a
criminal he never imagined having a
future at all let alone a future where
he was loved by someone and yet here he
was being told that it was going to
happen he would get more than he could
ever have hoped for
but just when he got everything he could
have ever wished for it all got snatched
away when he was away his sensei and his
fiancée were poisoned they were poisoned
because the APRA mentioned jealous
martial artists couldn't beat sensei
kaizo or Icaza
in a fair fight so they resorted to
poisoning their well once again ah cos I
couldn't save those who are most
precious to him he had promised to
protect his fiancee for his entire life
and he felt like he broke that promise
octa so went on to attack the rival dojo
that was responsible for the poisoning
he killed 67 swordsmen with his bare
hands as time passed no one could
believe that such a thing actually
happened and the recorded events of that
night were regarded as a fictitious tale
for 30 years before being a race Mouzon
showed up when akka son no longer wanted
to live a Kasai was turned into a demon
and lost his memories he kept wanting
strength even though he no longer had a
thing to protect and yet as a demon he
never killed women and eventually he
regains his emotions and as koyuki
points out returns to his original self
although as a demon he could have kept
fighting ton zero he decided to stop and
go to the afterlife gracefully
tragically he couldn't join the ones he
loved in heaven because of his actions
but he died happy because they never
stopped loving him now after hearing
that try and tell me that this isn't a
beautifully written character you can't
do it now let's turn to his powers he is
insanely strong he beat that angle Kuh
and would have probably defeated dance
of the fire-god time judo and awakened
Marc Gill if he didn't choose to die a
graceful death instead so for the record
we're talking insane power in his demon
form uh cuz I was already impressive
strength and fighting skills
dramatically increased not to mention
his regenerative power his blood demon
technique allows him to create shock
wave like attacks
it also allows him to detect blood lust
and fighting spirit in his enemies so he
can act quickly upper moon to was DOMA
the eccentric cult leader demon he was
born with rainbow colored eyes and was
groomed to be the religious leader of
the eternal paradise cult his father
kept making love to his female called
followers and as a result dolmas mother
stabbed him to death she went crazy and
killed herself with poison Dola wasn't
concerned about his parents being dead
though he was concerned about the mess
his mother made in the room not for a
moment that he feel sad or lonely human
emotions were nothing to him even before
he turned into a demon it was at age 20
that Mouzon officially turned him into a
demon DOMA was pretty busy as a demon
cult leader he wasn't sleeping with his
called followers as far as we know but
he was eating them at some point he
turned gu taro and aki into demons he
also crossed paths with eNOS gay
eNOS K's mother escaped to the eternal
paradise cult to get her and her baby
son away from an abusive household DOMA
actually intended to let her live out
her lifespan and not eat her she was
beautiful and had a great singing voice
however she found out that dolma was
eating other followers she fled and then
dropped baby noski off a cliff before
DOMA caught up and killed her DOMA
assumed that the baby was as good as
dead but as we know eNOS he is a tough
dude and managed to survive jungle book
style then there was the time he killed
kinetochore troll the flower pillar this
marked the end of him in a way because
kana his younger sister Shinobu coral
the insect pillar set out to get revenge
after her sister's death and she does
get a revenge
she feels her body with custom poison
and allows DOMA to eat her this poison
weakens him enough so that the adoptive
younger sister of Kanna and Nobu can
finish him off with a little help from
eNOS game this is one of the best
revenge arcs I've seen in anime and it
makes this fight one of my favorites
dolmas demon powers allow him to create
ice and frost by using his own flesh and
blood he uses two fans to help channel
his ice powers he can create ice clones
of himself to fight for him for his
strongest attack he can create a giant
bodhisattvas statue out of ice the
statue can attack
academies and it produces deadly cold
air that can freeze opponents however he
waited too long to use this attack and
since he was so weakened by the poison
DOMA and his Opie giant ice statue were
defeated and now we finally get to upper
Moon one who is kakushi Bo the six-eyed
Samurai
the strongest Moon demon used to be a
Demon Slayer named Mitch Akatsuki Cooney
before becoming a demon he had a child
that would keep his bloodline going for
centuries in fact the pillar mu Ichiro
tokoto is a descendant of this upper
moon cuckoo she will receive the mark
that drastically increases one's power
but as he later explains the marked ones
die before they reach the age of 25
those who show the mark after 25 will
quickly die turning into a demon was
away for kakushi bow to avoid death
while increasing his power even more he
served as the unbeatable number one moon
for centuries what's very interesting is
that the upper moon one kakushi bow uses
breath of the moon in battle he's so
strong that he's been winning against
Gill may the strongest pillar Sanna me
mu hero and ganya yo me and sauna me
even awaken their Demon Slayer marks yet
they're still having trouble keeping up
with the moon breath user as of chapter
172 every slash he makes with his sword
is surrounded by many crescent moon like
blades that change in size and length
besides power range and unpredictability
to his already Opie attacks his sword is
made out of his own flesh and has
multiple eyes on it which increase his
range of vision because it's made of his
own flesh it can regenerate when broken
or even change form even though they've
ganged up on him kikuchi bow is not
going to be easy to defeat there are
even theories that he's the brother of
the first breath of the Sun user since
they look so much alike
or perhaps breath of the Sun turns into
breath of the moon when you become a
demon since as we know by now the Sun
and demons don't go well together all we
know is that he's ridiculously
overpowered and more than a worthy
opponent for the strongest pillar I
wouldn't even be surprised if it turns
out that this guy has hoshi rama cells
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching I'm absolutely
in love with this series so I love the
fact that I get to make videos on it
make sure to smash that like button if
you enjoyed this video I want to see
more like it if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and bring that notification
bells you actually get notified when new
videos drop and if that's not enough
anime goodness for you you can follow us
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for even more let me know what other
Demon Slayer videos you would like to
see in the comments a big thank you goes
out to our patrons over on patreon who
help make videos like this one possible
I especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings out
just Angel Cruz and Steelers and other
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans baby ray a 17 FF DP Steven and
grata a Lola and attempt Mattie Mac 239
makoto-kun and keelon and the patrons
who transcend greatness itself Regan
Harrison and Lord Knutson or the chosen
few who have been acknowledged by Lord
we go himself if you enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon comm anime outdoor and becoming
a patron today for as little as $1 if
you do so you'll get your name feature
in future videos alongside these pillars
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
[Music]